this is the first time the two of you
have worked together on the big screen
so what took so long
we never cost we would have done it yeah
years ago someone had asked us I mean my
memory is such these days that if
someone said well actually you did do a
whole season with the time heaven when
you were youngsters in the Royal
Shakespeare Company I would say oh yes I
remember mr. and mrs. Santa that was
cool we could do that again what was
that movie we're back backstage at Dance
of Death it was Christmastime oh do you
remember yes we do you dressed up the
Sun do something about the person's
great you guys do you know who you are
you're the only person on this planet
who makes me feel that I'm not alone but
you go on the holiness in charge of our
own well thank goodness it ring yes
rings again I tell you one thing about
is not having worked together before it
does Adam and it becomes it to the firm
is that they've never met before
where did you guys film your own stunts
yes well we don't want to talk too much
by that okay fair enough
there are ways of doing things in film
that's yes make it safe yes
and I'm proselytizing for stunt people
to get Oscars must be nominated for
Oscars because some stunts are so
important no no no no don't touch
we are gonna be seeing you in Fast &
Furious yeah I'm what you've been
filming fans are so excited for them
obviously but cardi B has been added to
this exciting and song oh that's cool
wait singing you didn't get to know I
didn't get to what we call dB
oh that would be great I was in a car
with VIN which was a very nice place to
be so I was very happy REE behind the
wheel in that car and sir you have cats
coming out soon I do catch the musical
Gus what's up that cap tell us a little
bit more um the CGI is something the
stage show cats was not a lot about a
lot of people being convincing as cats
there's not bit but was about human
beings discover their cat-like nature
and a future set it was when it was done
and when it's not be done on film the
temptation I think must have been to
turn those actors into cats like Lion
King and make them look like real cats
but they're not real cats they're people
playing cats and that is that is the
notion of the film and it's been done
very recently I think and particularly
the dancers and to see a young person
discovering the cat in them young
georgeous drops with delight and
birthday Judy and I and James Corden and
all the rest Taylor Swift were all busy
doing our best and then I made the
sequences called dogs doing ferrets
great hamsters we're doing a wonderful
circle of hamster
[Music]